welcome to day two of a coffee zilla
christmas getting to a million
subscribers in one month obviously this
is a big challenge so we have to get in
the right grind set
ladies and gentlemen welcome to the 10
million dollar studio as you guys know
this isn't an ordinary challenge we
can't leave it to chance we gotta learn
from those who achieve the most in
society the super humans of the world to
learn how to get things done how to be
productive obviously i don't know what
i'm doing so i called in an expert on
the sigma grindset the master of fitness
the third eye himself philly on to learn
more phillian i'm here as your humble
student to learn the art of the grindset
how do we do it coffee listen you know
i'm all about that sigma mel grindset
all right welcome to today's
go ahead and stop dude hey i'm serious i
have to raise money for kids you need to
help me out here okay welcome to today's
masterclass on productivity because
remember while you're sleeping somebody
else is taking your bag all right and i
figured there's no better person to
start with than gary vee i i totally
agree dude that guy works harder than
anyone else how does he do it what's his
secret he's got one secret when it comes
to efficiency and that is he swallows
every piece of gum he's ever chewed
wait he doesn't he doesn't spit nope
he swallows
follow every piece of gum
i've swallowed every piece of gum that
i've ever chewed in my life
i don't think it's cool or anything i
don't think it's
amazing it's just the truth i think it's
efficiency i don't think i want to give
up the 100th of a second putting in a
napkin
no
no this is impossible this man is on
another wavelength yep he's not even
dude this wow well i thought we were
going to start at like how i can
optimize for the hours nope we're
starting with chewing gum okay because
it's it's the little things that add up
here if you can cut down seconds and i
mean milliseconds in your day you can
maximize productivity and get that bag i
really have a lot to learn here have you
ever heard of that uh
that's step one that child
tale where like if you swallow gum it
stays in your system for seven years
yeah this man is made of gum
dude i don't even want to think about
like what his bowel movements are like
so coffee you know tai lopez right yeah
what does he say about the best
investment you could possibly make
what does it make it in yourself do you
make it in yourself did i answer that
right yeah it's knowledge all right so
so in order to get this knowledge you
have to attend some master classes and
mentorship programs so next we're gonna
watch a video from v con it's garyvee's
own mentorship program right and he
asked some q a with the crowd and this
video
i think you're gonna like it
oh let's roll it
i mean it's so much more like
easier to say like oh it's just
perspective but like on the daily when
things are happening and i know you're
in the middle of doing something let's
say for your business who do you love
the most in the world
my fam i love i love when people just
they interrupt the thought and they just
start their own train of thought like
she's like hey you know when you run a
business who do you love most in the
world it's so obnoxious she's giving
like this heartfelt speech and he just
interrupts
hey that's all cool and stuff but uh
shut up for a second let me
uh shut up
let daddy talk okay it works 18 hours
you or me did you swallow your gum on
the way to work today i don't think so
okay pipe down
good who in your family pick one
all of them
you're very politically correct cool
every day
like wait wait wait wait
he's like stop i know you i know you
have a favorite come on
literally once a day
genuinely sit there for five minutes and
make pretend one of them got shot in the
face
i'm being dead
no no no no no no no this is fake no he
for real for five minutes a day
envisions the person he loves the most
with their face shot up yep getting shot
in the face point blank
why
dude what do you mean why
you should know this by now that's true
how stupid of me to ask dude you got to
take risks in life you know business is
savage out there it's cut throat you
gotta picture your loved ones getting
shot in the face to maximize profits
it's really rough out there it's really
not that complicated it's serious with
you every single day
i
almost i said this today earlier
i probably once a week to four times a
week
sit there truly in the shower on a
flight when i wake up some people
meditate
right some people work out i picture my
family getting shot in the face
i actually sit and truly try to convince
myself that i have lost one of the five
most important people in my life and
that is the biggest thing i do that
leads to the biggest happiness i have
[Music]
wait he imagines
his loved ones getting shot
and then i just imagine his a smile
creeps up on garyvee's face you can't
tell me he's not a sociopath okay all
right well uh uh i gotta admit we're off
to a bad start so
i can't i can't spit out my gum anymore
we're swallowers now and we must imagine
our loved ones dead i was you know i was
kind of hoping for something about
working hard you know
i got you
okay good good give it to me you ever
hear of shreds
no who's that so shreds was a fitness
company probably about five to eight
years ago and they got busted for a ton
of fraud but that's not important okay
wait don't say anything more you had me
at fraud
tell me his secrets
[Music]
dude there is there there is such thing
as being too handsome
dude he looks like he was carved out of
marble what is up with this face dude
this is the final boss
is this the jar size guy the guy where
you like chew the thing and it makes
your jaw super strong oh the the jaws
are size no no oh gosh and what's so
special guys should be their model
nothing
i'm just like
[Music]
no you're not
dude this guy's built different
he's got everything
every morning
you can either
dude look at how many likes it has dude
1.6 likes zero dislikes this is a very
well liked video dude we're gonna go and
slap a like on it dude oh man this is me
looking at my future dude future is
bright
that's it right there right bro dude
look at those traps those are traps of
success right there
hey what do you think can we do a quick
fitness flop is this guy is this guy on
the gear what what is this guy he is
audi he's on all the gear dude okay
uh i need some of that gear for my face
[Laughter]
i won't tell you what food to eat
i won't tell you what supplements to
take
but i will
tell you the secret to success
you gotta have your eyes gotta have your
nipples out all december
there is none
that's it coffee there's there's no
secret
wait what those are all his phones
dude he's a traitor but he trades on all
those phones at the same time it's just
him just
that's why
well um
i think you know what i did think i
learned something from that and that is
to think of working while you're
sleeping that's a next level
move all right what what else do we have
here because i don't i need something
for my mind too i mean i'm gonna be
relentlessly going through this month of
course i gotta have something for just
not just my body which will be roided
out by the end of this year you will see
yeah but i also need something for my
mind so we're going to learn from the
best now this is forbes you know forbes
right they do like the 30 under 30. all
millionaires yeah yeah yeah all
millionaires yeah all of them very
successful very legit so this is a
series called the relentless and i mean
it kind of speaks for itself
i wake up every day at 4 30 i work out
shower meditate and get dressed
sometimes my meditation is just a quick
minute to remind me to keep working hard
and always be grateful
remember if you're going to three
seconds where i think of my dad lying on
the cold floor dead also helps a little
bit too
i'm sorry i shouldn't i shouldn't joke i
lie at the feet of the master i'm sorry
to make fun of this i i am here to learn
i don't usually wear a suit to work but
this is the time of year when most
charities have their annual benefit
dinners i plug in my headphones and
start listening to my audio books i
listen at three times the normal speed
and get through a little more than
yep
you ever listen to audiobooks at three
times speed
no i have it is that is that the move is
that
quite literally inaudible like you can't
understand it wait i think
in testament to this man we should
listen to this entire thing on 2x okay i
almost gave you by train so i use an
absolute my weight on the flat ones i
want to train five seconds i'm in the
office i try to get twenty five miles an
hour in the morning
wait there's too much here
he's in the office by seven a.m how does
he get to work i i've already lost so
much he
he walks miles after he's worked out
yeah so he wakes up at 4 30 he meditates
about
working hard
and then he listens to an audiobook at
three times speed as he walks to the
train station but he uses an app to
minimize the amount of time so he never
misses a train he's like never late
right then he gets to the office at 7 00
am but he's got a standing desk with a
treadmill attachment so he can get some
more steps in people have to be roasting
this guy let's go check out the likes
dislikes oh dude everyone loves it again
everyone loves it crazy dude how many
people just love no one sees through it
i guess no dislikes
i mean
he's just on that grind setting it's
nothing but respect from me you know 15
minutes every day
today
i'm sorry i i'm sorry i know it's so
uh beta of me but i got to turn this
down to normal i can't even hear him
hold on i'll i'll let it slide this time
but come on okay all of my internal
group meetings with three deep breaths
it helps me get centered and bring my
attention to the meeting
then i'm off to grab a quick bite
my next meeting's in midtown so i get on
the train and listen to music i'm done
by 5 45 and headed to the gala i keep my
girlfriend posted on my eta tonight
we're supporting an education charity
for children of lesser means in south
africa
i'm out by nine and in bed by 10 30.
waking up early to do it all again
tomorrow there you go i mean what do you
say
in bed by 10 10 30. so that's six hours
of sleep
whoa
what is this guy this guy's greedy he's
a little he's a little greedy little if
i'm being honest i mean i thought 3x
speed i thought he was something but now
that i hear you sleeping what six hours
a night yeah it's too much sleep well
yeah i will tell you i have been looking
into this i've been doing some self
research myself and i did find out that
um this guy obviously isn't worth
anything because i i heard a quote
apparently all billionaires wake up at
exactly 4 a.m do you hear about this
yeah it's common knowledge it's part of
this grind set bible dude well yeah i
mean thanks a lot for telling me philly
on i mean i appreciate it that's why
we're having this master class yeah
that's right yeah look at this dude six
million people are billionaires they all
watch this and they all got on their
grind set so we're going to join them
absolutely why are successful people
waking up at 4am but not
oh
sorry
too fast too fast for me i apologize
different hour what is the secret behind
it
well they know how their brain works and
they take advantage of their brainwave
states and brain
chemistry produces electrical patterns
often referred to as waves when you're
first awake your brain operates at
around ten and a half waves per second
yeah cause you're not awake you're tired
dude when i wake up i can't think i'm
operating at about three waves per
second when i wake up
yeah that's why you're broke you know
that's why you're not a billionaire dude
billionaires are at that other level the
range from 8 to 13 hertz or cycles per
second is the alpha stage it's been
called the gateway to the subconscious
mind but when you wake up this early you
are between theta and alpha
where did they get this research the joe
rogan institute i mean where did this
grow science come from dude i think
jocko willink
yeah probably the mind is capable of
deep and profound learning being fully
aware and focused
this was just gary vee with like a voice
modulator
to take off the mask
he just has a monopoly on all these
motivations
yeah now speaking of i want to talk
about this for a second because there is
a day in the life of gary vee i mean
maybe we should check out what time he
wakes up it's got to be something like
if if it's not 4 am i'm not impressed
dude true true true
[Music]
oh 5 15.
[Music]
what
6 am he's playing basketball with the
boys dunking on joe rogan
yeah dude this is impossible
[Music]
all right gary get the get to the point
[Music]
i just got to know when he goes to sleep
let's skip ahead a little bit
meeting with drock 8 p.m he's having a
dinner business meeting he's still he
dude he's still working 9 30 10 45 he's
still working
11 15. he's traveling
business calls
bro
if gary vee calls me at 11 35 at night
i'm hanging out i'm jumping out the
[ __ ] window dude
okay so
so i guess the answers don't sleep and
what kind of products are because
obviously
everyone here is on something we got to
get on something here right the secret
is i'm not you know hardcore enough
i got to get on something what do you
suggest what kind of supplements are we
talking we got to get a doctor
prescribed billionaire starter juice
pack jeff bezos is on it elon musk is on
it yes okay basically it starts with a
base of testosterone the male sex
hormone it'll get it'll get your mood
right it'll get you hungry for success
and physically you know you got to eat
more you got to fuel your body if you're
going to be working all the all these
hours and then maybe we can start
experimenting with some some stuff that
joe rogan recommends but you know we're
not there yet yeah yeah yeah yeah okay
all right all right well do you know
anybody who who's on that that regiment
any billionaires you know any billion
dollar men
i just told you
jeff bezos and elon musk oh but are they
posting videos about it no but grant
cardone is i'll do well hey that's
enough for me dude let's watch it's just
walking around his [ __ ] like colorado
mansion talking about how he's just on
testosterone it's like the fountain of
youth
hey grant cardone here and so many of
you been asking me what i'm taking to
lean up and grow muscle mass i wanted to
let you know what i'm doing about 12
months ago i started researching
what i could do to take better care of
myself
now in that period of time over the
years i had tried thousands of
supplements hundreds of tubs of protein
probably like you that i had in my
kitchen i've tried every kind of protein
possible and i always knew there had to
be a better way i wonder what can i do
to get leaner
maximum energy increased stamina i need
deeper sleep and i want to build muscle
mass
steroids yes the answer is steroids i
love how he's just like skirting around
the entire like elephant in the room
yeah oh this is great you know 60 years
of age it becomes more and more
difficult and my body was starting to
experience lots
of stress maybe of time and
joint pains and discomforts a friend of
mine reached out to me he said i've been
working with a group that has a doctor
prescribed medication
that is a game changer
he introduced me to the group i did a
survey with them
and they prescribed me this medication
for deeper sleep increased energy
extended stamina and for the first time
in years
i was starting to grow some muscle mass
man i was starting to cut some of the
fat that had accumulated i told the
group it's streamlined hey you guys got
to figure out how to get this to my
people my 10x family the 10x
entrepreneurs
and you have to make it affordable
look not only did they make all that
possible they called it or they call it
10x health systems and i'm so pumped up
oh my gosh he's just chilling just his
own stuff is it supplements
i love how every it's not even
supplements dude because it's doctor
prescribed like we're talking gear oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah
wow he's like we got to make it
affordable it's got to be accessible to
everyone it's gotta be accessible to our
billionaires hey
listen dude we got we've got some
discerning billionaires here
they're tough with their checkbook okay
we gotta get
got to get the price down okay so um so
gear so i need to get on a lot of gear
[Laughter]
and uh so what else i mean i need i need
something really to nail this part
finish it
get me all the way home right
swallowing a little gum isn't gonna do
it for me philly on waking up a little
bit earlier may not do it for me gear
probably will if i'm being very dear
will get you there yeah gear will get me
there what what else
how do you feel about mondays well i i
don't really like them i mean
why not well i guess because it's the
start of the week yeah and that means
making more money dude how how could i
have not seen this yeah okay okay sure
sure so
who better to learn about mondays and
why he loves mondays than david goggins
okay that's he's sigma for sure alpha
maybe he's full alpha i think he's more
sigma i don't know the difference
so i'd hide
you'll get there if you pan it down here
you see it's about three o'clock in the
morning
yes dude finally someone who's working
hard
at last i see somebody who's not just
some beta
dude waking up at 5am absolute bum yeah
uh
yeah a car or a person inside if you pan
over here
no billionaires in sight they're not up
they wake up at four yeah they wake up
before you know where i find my strength
at where i get my strength i get it from
a lot of places i gotta be honest i
believe dave david goggins actually does
this i don't think any anyone else in
this entire thing actually does the
morning routines they say they do yeah i
believe david goggins actually does i
think he's i think he's really out there
doing this yeah i think i think he's the
only guy who hasn't figured out that no
one else is doing it he's like where are
they everybody says they're waking up at
three nobody's out here that's funny
dude just goes to garyvee's house
he's like gary
not there not there [ __ ] that's
up
there's not a car there's not a person
everybody's in their bed sleep dreading
that it's a monday haters on monday and
i'm loving it i'm loving that where
everybody's getting weaker i'm getting
stronger
it's not about the running the swimming
to push up the sit-ups it's about what
those things do for your mentality you
don't get better on the daggone couch
you get better by coming out here and
getting the [ __ ] after every daggone day
stay hard
it's got to stay hard dude
[Music]
hey i think i might need some of that uh
grant cardone stuff i don't want to stay
that hard okay it's got to stay bricked
up 24 7.
i got to be honest with you i don't know
if i'm capable
of the sigma grind set i'm starting to
get a little worried your mindset's just
not there you can't you can't be having
these negative intrusive thoughts
dangits how do i
how do i fix it are you willing to
sacrifice temporary comfort for
long-term success
probably not but i'll try my best all
right we're about to watch your video by
grant cardone
in which he poses that exact same
question to a 13 year old what advice
would you have to give to someone young
like me and what can i start doing now
first of all you're doing the right
thing being here give him a hand for
just being there
imagine being a 13 year old at a
grant cardone 10x conference his parents
have to be there right oh yeah for sure
or
bought his ticket dude they're the ones
who loaded them up or you think he woke
up he offered 13 year old financing does
he offer 13 year old financing you'll
see how to leverage your age how old are
you
13. you're a killer bro you're a killer
you need a target okay i want to give
you a target of like how much are you
going to make this year
i have no idea yeah well there you go
that's the problem okay i'm going to
give this guy a target at 10 000 between
now and the end of the year i need you
to produce ten thousand dollars worth of
income you got five months to do it it's
two grand a month 500 bucks a week how
many subs you need to a million i think
like a hundred seventy thousand how much
is that per day i don't know is it a bad
thing it's gotta be like five to six k a
day right yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah all
right so you got to establish targets
you can't you can't be just going in
here raw dog oh willy nilly expecting to
just hit a million subs what do you but
how many per second now that is finally
the question yeah i think it's like
three a second actually
there's no chance i got no shot
i feel worse right now yeah there's no
way i feel worse no dude there is there
has to be a way we gotta save the
children what's your business gonna be
um repairing phones what do you repair
phones well uh yeah what kind of phones
all of them how many of you want to help
this guy out with this new business
video here's a here's another customer
dude here's another customer
here's 20. here's 60.
he just takes it right
make more money today
i'm guaranteeing you a double all you
got to do is show me this money december
31st what could you do today to
guarantee yourself think creatively
get to you we're partners now okay all
right i got your money call me back on
december 31 you want it back your choice
you want it now
you trust yourself or you trust me you
okay okay he's bro that kid is never
getting his money never
okay this is what he did with the kids
money right here
yeah this was posted after that video
too yeah yeah yeah
so sinister
i don't know i i still feel i still
don't understand how this is going to
get us to where we need to go
wait hold on let's go
hold up hold up sorry
sorry i i didn't realize you're you're
you're uh multitasking while being here
with me today dude um this is sigma dude
this is very sigma this is a good lesson
you're watching the grind set unfold
before your eyes okay
leon i just feel beat down
i feel crushed the only good advice i've
had all day is the steroids that's
probably the best
i think we watch one more by my favorite
my favorite entrepreneur who is it dan
pena
that alex wants a case study because he
wants to know that behind it because
he's stupid and that's why he's [ __ ]
poor
this is why you're [ __ ] poor this is
why the sucker's watching this on
youtubers so [ __ ] poor
that's awesome wow dude i feel yes it's
all coming together he's talking about
dudes wait no it's no no phil it's it's
all finally coming together i'm
achieving
sigma enlightenment he directly just
yelled at us
yeah
he's dude he's so right this is why this
is why i've been asking too many
questions i gotta shut up you gotta
listen shut my mouth listen up you know
what
i think um
i think that finally did it that's it
that's all you need why why you're poor
unlocked something i think in me
obviously i i don't have any money i
know we did discuss payment but i'm
going to have to put it on layaway yep
dan pena was right i am poor
and i i will have no money especially
especially after this month the stupid
children are getting it
i hate to say
uh so i don't i don't know what to say
but um you will receive your payment
sometime in 2032.
ten years from now
yeah
is that is that like uh
i'm gonna get off my grind set dude i'm
saying goodbye to my 20s goodbye to my
30s i'm on it dude
you've helped me achieve enlightenment
and i for this i'm forever grateful of
course